le monde entier dépens des énergies sous
plusieurs formes elles s'insèrent dans
nos
l'énergie
l'énergie nucléaire est l'énergie
électrique ce type d'énergie elles
interagissent entre elles à travers leur
production et leur consommation
nous utilisons des combustibles fossiles
pour produire notre électricité à
travers une réaction chimique ou
nucléaire
nous utilisons de l'essence pour nous
déplacer nous chauffer alors je pense
qu'il est facile d'admettre que l'homme
civilisé dépenses de différentes formes
d'énergie
pourtant vous devez le savoir
l'énergie est là pas trop la cote ces
temps ci mais je devrais plutôt dire il
ya une mauvaise élève et cette mauvaise
élève c'est les énergies fossiles
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu à
travers notre utilisation dans notre
société des énergies fossiles on
engendre de la pollution de l'air et la
pollution des sols
nous utilisons notre voiture l'avion
notre habit qui est produit à l'étranger
notre maquillage et même notre
électricité à titre d'exemple en chine
la pollution de l'air qui est issu de
l'industrie et du transport tue environ
un mille 1 25 million d'habitants par
année dans le monde ses 4,2 millions de
personnes qui meurent de la pollution de
l'air sont les chiffres de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
alors serait-il bien phu pouvoir penser
s'en débarrasser comment est ce que l'on
va faire pour nous séparer de ceux qui
empoisonnent de plus en plus notre ville
nos villages même les montagnes et les
glaciers du monde et bien à l'heure
actuelle le monde possède des soluces
des solutions de transition vers
lesquels on peut se diriger qui vont
nous permettre peut-être de baisser
notre pollution de l'air et notre
empreinte carbone
je pense notamment à la voiture
électrique
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'elle
ne consomme plus d'essence et ne produit
pas directement de co2 alors on se dit
ah premier lieu c'est magnifique c'est
une technologie incroyable pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas tous des voitures
électriques
et bien tout simplement parce que comme
je le dit une solution de transition
pourquoi parce que elle elle peut ne pas
répondre totalement à la problématique
mais la déplacer ailleurs ce n'est pas
l'utilisation de la voiture électrique
qui peut produire des gaz à effet de
serre mais c'est ce dont elle dépend sa
batterie et son électricité
la batterie dépend de lithium qui est
issu de mines et le lithium c'est un
minerai qui est faux cils l'exploitation
du lithium pollue beaucoup mais si on
vient à l'électricité comment est ce que
nous on utilise comment est ce que nous
avons produit notre électricité
eh ben elle est issue en suisse
principalement des barrages et des
réacteurs nucléaires
ça nous passe ça nous pose en bon élève
dans le monde dedans et en europe
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que la
production d'électricité à travers les
réacteurs nucléaires ne pollue pas
directement
elle ne relâche pas de co2 mais c'est
l'exploitation de l'uranium ou d'autres
matériaux rifi qui polluent alors en
suisse
on comprend donc que l'utilisation de la
voiture électrique peut se faire parce
que notre émission par l'électricité est
propre mais la suisse elle veut se
débarrasser de ses réacteurs nucléaires
alors on va avoir un trou de production
d'électricité qu'il va falloir remplacer
par un autre secteur
et là je pense notamment aux panneaux
solaires aux éoliennes
pourquoi parce que c'est re cesser ses
producteurs ses productions d'énergie
dépendent de ressources naturelles
illimitée le vent et le soleil
alors on se dit jackpot c'est encore une
solution à notre problème mais pourtant
vous alliez y être habitué il ya
toujours des petits problèmes et le
premier c'est justement qu'on dépend de
ses ressources naturelles ça n'implique
non seulement que l'investisseur ne
choisit pas quand il veut produire son
électricité car ils dépendent ces
phénomènes est aussi que la production
n'est pas stable elle est soumise à des
hausses et des baisses elle est
intermittente
et ça ça nous amène à une obligation
qu'on a si on veut pas produire pas
gaspiller d'énergie ou ne pas produire à
perte
on doit stocker cette énergie et en
suisse comme je les dis on a des
barrages et je sais pas si vous avez
aimé les barrages nous permettent de de
produire d'électricité par an faisant
tomber de l'eau dans des conduites pour
faire tourner des turbines et produire
excité mais on peut aussi stocker notre
énergie
parce qu'en faisant la marche inverse
c'est-à-dire en amenant de l'eau dans le
barrage on peut la turbine et plus tard
on a donc une batterie et alors là c'est
génial mais qu'en est il des villes
comment est ce que dans les villes on
peut facilement stocker l'énergie et ben
ça nous amène aux batteries je vais
prendre l'exemple de la californie du
sud
aux etats unis 10 l'aï installé plus de
390 6 énorme frigo qui sont en fait des
batteries et ses batteries permettent de
stocker de l'énergie en surplus qui est
produite par des énergies intermittentes
vous les redistribuer le soir à plus de
15 mille habitations
c'est génial mais pourtant ça amène un
autre problème c'est que les batteries
et ben ça coûte cher alors à la base
notre production d'électricité sont
magnifiques mais avec l'ajout du coût
des batteries on devient de moins en
moins en moins concurrentiel
ensuite l'infrastructure nécessaire pour
une ferme solaire et fatalement grande
pourquoi parce que si on veut produire
beaucoup d'électricité avec des panneaux
solaires
on ne peut pas les empiler bien sûr
alors si on veut produire beaucoup
électricité on doit avoir une grande
production
une grande surface et ça dans les villes
c'est encore une fois un autre problème
mais ce problème peut avoir une solution
parce qu'imaginez le pouvoir des toits
je parle bien sûr pas de la charpente ni
des tuiles le bien de la surface qu'il
représente
imaginez les toits de martigny sion et
sierre réunis quelle est la surface que
ça représente ces gigantesques et ben
c'est là que peut entrer l'action
citoyenne
c'est à dire un privé qui peut installer
des panneaux solaires sur son toit et
une batterie dans son garage
c'est dans son garage justement où il ya
la meilleure place pour une voiture
électrique parce que vous savez d'où
vient votre électricité vous le
produisez vous même de ressources
naturelles limitées
alors après avoir découvert les
opportunités le pouvoir qu'on avait
peut-être de rendre les choses un peu
meilleur je pense qu'il est temps de
voir le verre à moitié vide
pourquoi parce que nous même si c'est
uniquement stratégique de savoir qu'est
ce que l'on peut faire si on n'atteint
pas nos objectifs carbone ce que la
politique a fixé qu'est ce qu'on a comme
solution je vous en parlais d'une qui
est assez intéressante parce qu'elle est
limitée par des facteurs politiques
c'est la captation de carbone
je suis vous avez un exemple de quelque
chose qui capte le carbone dans la
nature
exactement les arbres les plantes etc
bien sûr il existe enfin la science
évolue et université columbia aux états
unis a développé une feuille synthétique
qui captent mille fois plus de carbone
qu'un arbre et après permet de le
stocker on se dit incroyable c'est une
solution magnifique mais il y a encore
une fois un petit problème et ce petit
problème c'est que quand des oeuvres des
industries investissent dans un nouveau
secteur
elles tiennent compte d'une sorte de
prix carbone et ce prix carbone dans la
fourchette haute se situer entre 10 et
30 $ la tonne de co2 les pays en europe
et dans le monde qui produisent plus de
co2 que leur quota politique c'est
doivent acheter la différence à deux
pays et il s'échange 7 tonne carbone à
32 euros la tonne
si on revient à notre innovation la
feuille synthétique
elle a un rendement de 2 100 dollars la
tonne de co2 on voit bien qu'elle est
extrêmement peu concurrentiel face à ce
que les industries et la politique c'est
change c'est bien alors j'espère que on
avait pu réaliser qu'on avait des
solutions les opportunités qu'on avait
et je pense qu'il est notre devoir de
nous mobiliser pour mettre en place ces
solutions à travers notre engagement
public privé ou même politique parce
qu'on l'a su se mobiliser les jeunes ont
su se mobiliser que ce soit pour les
droits de la femme ou pour la planète
alors fait ressortir la flamme qui vous
anime pour à travers votre engagement
qu'on puisse mettre en place une espèce
de symbiose entre le monde politique le
monde scientifique et le monde
économique parce que sans ça on voit que
rien ne peut fonctionner et c'est en ça
on ne peut pas offrir un autre
génération et celles futures un monde
meilleur un monde plus propre
merci
[Applaudissements]